bonjour et bienvenue sur minutes forme
je me présente je suis federico
aujourd'hui avec cuisine si eva braun
qu'elle aujourd'hui on va voir un
travail sur les abdos le monde mouvant
s'appelle levée cela on va pouvoir
travailler
la sangle abdominale et en même temps
faire un léger stretching à léger
étirement sur l'arrière de la crise
justement ça sa position n'est pas et
allongé sur le sol les deux pays à plat
je loue dans laxe et on a tout
simplement temps d'une jambe en
contractant du quadriceps on attrape
derrière la jambe et ont fait un rôle de
bus quand on est au bout du mouvement
ont bien faire un léger étirement sur la
jambe pour pouvoir tirer l'ischio
jambier et on refait le chemin contraire
on n'altère la droite
et à gauche depuis la pl on va attendre
une jambe contractée un petit peut
accueillir les 120 petits peut on bien
attraper des arts la cuisse et au mot le
buste en scellant de la jambe quand on
descend on peut faire la droite et à
gauche on note la même chose
donc quand on remonte un petit travail
sur la sangle abdominale et quand on est
au bout du mouvement à l'étirement sur
l'escaut janvier très bien tu le ressens
et de mouvement on va pouvoir effectuer
mêlant à l'étirement sur la paroi
abdominale je vais pouvoir plaisir de te
tourner et thème est allongé les mains
tu vas les positionner en face aux
auteurs et faire un relevé de bus 30 ou
sans supplément à l'étirement basique on
l'avait déjà vu pour la paroi abdominale
donc le travail est ciblé vraiment sur
l'assemblage le retour
vous pouvez toujours retrouver nos
étirements et nos mouvements lors des
anciennes émissions de minutes forme
merci suzy versant boiteau à bientôt sur
une tv cinaps les muscles sollicités
sont les abdos entraînez-vous cinq fois
par semaine en effectuant 5 séries en 2
15 répétition durant cet exercice
conserver une jambe tendue en même temps
que le relevé des bus